-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Well, guys,
tonight was the drawing
for the $1.3 billion
Mega Millions jackpot,
the second largest in history.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Whoa.
-The odds of winning
were one in 302 million.
[ Laughter ]
But I have a system.
I buy two tickets.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cluck ]
Everyone always says that
they'll be smart with the money
and then they spend
the next three hours scrolling
through photos
of lawn fountains.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Hey, found one."
But the lottery can be fun,
especially before the drawing,
when people say to their boss,
"Quick heads up -- you might get
a profanity-laced phone call
from me tonight.
Talk to you later.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, but today is
Friday the 13th.
-Whoa.
[ Cheering, oohs,
and applause ]
People say it's unlucky.
Meanwhile, everyone who flew
Southwest over the holidays
was like, "Last month
wasn't so lucky,
[ Laughter and applause ]
either."
That's right,
today is Friday the 13th.
-Careful.
Careful there, Jimmy.
It's not over yet.
-Well, actually, I had
a great Friday the 13th.
It's Hot Dog Friday here at NBC.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I'm going to save this
for later.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bloop! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't forget the bun, hon.
[ Bloop! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Clapping ]
Cool!
-This is the best
Friday the 13th ever!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Congratulations, bud!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Oohs ]
Well, get this --
I saw that tomorrow,
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas Tree comes down.
[ Awws and applause ]
And --
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
-And hold on to your
ticket stubs
because one lucky audience
member will be taking it home.
That's right.
[ Oohs, cheering,
and applause ]
People always ask,
"What happens to the tree?"
Well, it's actually shipped
to a paper mill,
where it becomes thousands
of mishandled
classified documents.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yep, everyone's still talking
about the classified documents
that were found
in President Biden's garage.
[ Laughter ]
Even worse, it came out
that his neighbor asked
to borrow one
and still hasn't returned it.
[ Laughter ]
But it might help
explain things.
According to a new report,
Biden's last few days
as vice president were chaotic
and boxes were being packed
until the last minute.
Biden was like, "That's it,
I'm changing my review
on College Hunks Hauling Junk.
[ Laughter ]
Losers."
Of course,
Democrats are concerned
this scandal could weaken Biden
as a candidate in 2024,
as opposed to their
previous concern,
that the ravages of time
would weaken him by 2024.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine losing the most
powerful job on Earth
because you kept putting off
cleaning out the garage.
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news --
it seems like every day
we're learning more
about George Santos
and I actually saw a clip
from back in October,
where he and his opponent were
asked the same question, okay?
And I'm surprised nobody
noticed this.
Take a look.
This is real.
-So, Mr. Zimmerman, name one
of your favorite
family traditions.
-Oh, my nephews and I,
my brother, and sister-in-law
get together in our sweats
and eat the food that we
shouldn't eat all year round.
It goes into -- Haagen-Dazs
is always a staple.
-Mr. Santos, your favorite
family tradition.
-Every moment
we can get together
that's kind of a down time,
it's sweatpants,
pints of Haagen-Dazs all
over the place.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-That's for real.
-What?!
-Oh, my God.
-I've never seen identity theft
happen in real time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That's my favorite moment.
That's weird."
Then he said,
"I'm Marcia Kramer,
host of 'The Point.'
Thanks for watching.
Good night."
[ Laughter ]
And you go, "Wait."
Is that bizarre?
-My God.
-Switching gears --
I heard that ABC is planning
a new series called
"Jeopardy! Masters,"
where the highest-ranked
"Jeopardy!" contestants
will face off to win the title
of Jeopardy! Masters Champion.
[ Oohs ]
Yeah. And, while we don't know
much more about the show,
we do know that these
contestants missed the cut.
-Sam.
-What is Jamaica?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-What's a raccoon?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-What is seven?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Ray.
-Who are the Beastie Boys?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-What is a beaver?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Who's Ed Asner?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
And finishing off...
-Who is Shrek?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Unfortunate.
That's tough.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That was good stuff.
-"What is a beaver?"
-[ Laughs ]
-You guys -- Hey, guys,
everyone's excited about this --
the NFL playoffs kick off
tomorrow and --
[ Cheering and applause ]
The NFL.
And this is incredible --
Tom Brady is going
for his eighth Super Bowl.
[ Oohs ]
Yeah. When he heard,
George Santos was like,
"He's only one behind me."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, for the first time
in six years,
the New York Giants
made the playoffs.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Then the Jets were like,
"Just say New York is
in the playoffs, okay?
[ Laughter ]
Why do you have to be
so specific?"
That's right,
there will be a ton
of great games this weekend.
Tomorrow night, you can watch
the Jacksonville Jaguars
take on the Los Angeles Chargers
right here on NBC.
[ Cheering and applause ]
The game is two of the league's
best young quarterbacks,
Trevor Lawrence
and Justin Herbert.
Can we see them?
Yeah, there they are.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Well, today,
Trevor Lawrence said...
[ Laughter ]
And Justin Herbert said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then Brenden Schooler,
from the Patriots, said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Andrew Van Ginkel,
from the Dolphins, said...
[ Laughter ]
Tanner Muse, from the Seahawks,
said...
[ Laughter ]
Then George Kittle,
from the 49ers, said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Billy Price,
from the Cardinal, said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Finally --
Finally, Las Vegas Raiders
owner Mark Davis said...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Indistinct ]
Should be a good game.
Some entertainment news --
a new action movie,
called "Plane," opened today,
[ Oohs ]
about a heroic pilot,
but I was a little surprised
that they couldn't think
of a better name than "Plane."
[ Laughter ]
But regardless,
judging by the trailer,
it looks great.
Check it out.
-A determined pilot
will do anything
to rescue his passengers in the
pulse-pounding thriller...
...from the people
who brought you...
[ Laughter ]
Wow. That looks good.
I like that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, listen to this --
I saw a new study that found
that sitting too much
is hazardous to your health.
Yeah, that explains why I feel
so healthy eating Domino's
while standing
over the kitchen sink.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, this is --
this is actually real footage.
What I'm going to show you is --
-This is real.
-This one is real, yeah.
This is not a joke.
But this security footage
caught this moment.
A man in Brazil
was closing up his shop
with his father-in-law, okay?
And, well, just watch this
and enjoy it.
-[ Whistling ]
[ Squeak ]
[ Whistling ]
[ Audience gasping ]
[ Clanging ]
[ Ohhs ]
-[ Crying out
in foreign language ]
-[ Speaking
foreign language ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Ohhs ]
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Gasping ]
[ Clang ]
[ Ohhs, laughter,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Wow.
-Come on.
-That --
That happened seven more times.
[ Laughter ]
His father was all --
His father-in-law's like,
"Wait, I don't remember that."
[ Laughter ]
Then the father-in-law's like,
"Let me recover for a moment
by lying on the ground
with my legs spread wide."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Once again, just a reminder --
this weekend is
NFL Super Wild Card Weekend
and NBC has two big games...
-Whoa!
-...the Chargers versus
the Jaguars on Saturday night;
then Sunday night, it's the
Ravens versus the Bengals.
So, just stay right here
on NBC all weekend.
It's going to be good!
[ Cheering and applause ]
We appreciate it.
But first, what a show
we have for you tonight.
She is starring
in the Broadway revival
of "Funny Girl,"
which is playing now
at the August Wilson Theatre.
Lea Michelle is here tonight!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow.
-Plus, you know her as Max
from "Stranger Things."
You can also see her
in the new movie "The Whale,"
which is in theaters now.
Sadie Sink is here!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Drumming ]
And we got music from Dayglow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, today is Friday
and that's usually
when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox, return emails,
and I write out
some thank you notes
and I was wondering
if I could write some tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Is that okay?
James, can I get some thank you
note-writing music please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
-Jeez!
-He's in a good mood.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, "Plane,"
for being in the one flight this
week that didn't get canceled.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Appreciate it.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Dr Pepper-flavored Peeps,
for, somehow, not being called
Dr Peepers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why not?
-It's right there.
-Why wouldn't you do it?
-Why would you not?
-What?
At least Dr. Pibb.
-Call me. These people have
to call me.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, people with Christmas
decorations still up...
[ Laughter ]
for introducing your neighbors
to the fun new game
Lazy, Out of Town, or Dead?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not necessarily healthy.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Fresh laughter ]
Thank you, gas stoves,
for looking like
I'm staring down
at a Troll doll drum circle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Fruit by the Foot,
for being the red carpet
of fruit leather.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, Scratch-Off
lottery tickets,
for pretty much being the only
reason people still use coins.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, that's interesting.
-[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, today,
for being Friday the 13th,
which means only one thing...
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
It's Patrick Dempsey's birthday!
[ Hip hop oompah music plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Clapping rhythmically ]
There you have it!
Those were my Thank You Notes.
When we come back,
we're playing Charades
with Lea Michele, Sadie Sink.
Stick around, everybody!
♪♪